se tuer l'avortement ou avant que
l'avortement de tulle amérique tu es
l'avortement c'est l'objectif des anti
ivg depuis presque quarante ans aux
états unis les personnes qui remettent
en cause le droit des femmes à avorter
un droit acquis dans le pays depuis 1973
les adversaires de l'avortement qui ont
organisé pour le 22 janvier une grande
manifestation à washington ont dit
qu'ils voulaient faire parler d'eux par
tous les moyens au début des années 80
les manifestations anti avortement se
multiplient dans tout le pays une
révolution conservatrice menée et
encouragé par le président républicain
de l'époque ronald reagan de quoi jeter
nouveau pose le problème de l'avortement
nous rend à la gorge est-ce que
l'avortement tu olivier humaine ou non
un dvd six actuelles et que la médecine
le monde est de plus en plus il faut
l'arrêter et mon speech date ne pourra
arrêter les avortements certains
n'hésitent pas à employer la manière
forte menace attentat à la bombe
perpétré contre des centres ivg mêmes
assassinat font partie des méthodes
employées par quelques fanatiques en
1995 pour se protéger ce médecin avait
dû s'équiper je ne suis jamais très loin
d'une arme
quand des maniaques vos menaces de mort
reste est désarmé n'est pas très
judicieux 1
dans les années 90 les pro vie comme il
se surnomme exerce une pression
constante sur les tuniques et ça porte
ses fruits
entre 1992 et 2002 neil établissements
pratiquant l'avortement ont fermé leurs
portes selon l'institut de recherche
américain good mareuil une réalité qui
inquiétait cette féministe en l'an 2000
j'ai très peur que l'amérique revienne
en arrière
j'espère qu'on perde nos droits nos
libertés qu'on perde le respect pour les
petites gens
et ce droit à avorter pourrait bientôt
ne plus être garanties la cour suprême
envisagerait de renverser l'arrêt de
1973 selon le site d'information
américain politico
en clair ça signifie que chaque état
américain pourra légiférer sol ivg comme
bon lui semble
[Musique]